eight news stories appeared on social
media and the hours after the mass
shooting in Las Vegas some people
looking for information read and then
shared those false articles without even
realizing that it wasn't true two-thirds
of American adults use social media to
get their news these days Jim Axelrod is
here with a fight against the
misinformation there's a lot of
misinformation these days Jim welcome
there certainly is good morning social
media has seen a shift from a way to
share personal pictures and status
updates to one of the main ways people
get their news but the platforms have
struggled to keep a lid on incorrect
information and as we've seen over the
last 48 hours false news takes a very
real personal toll the damn elites have
been getting death threats and would
like people to know that social media is
fun this out of control
the daughters of Giri Dan Lee say their
father is innocent his ex-wife Mary Lou
Dan Lee is considered a person of
interest in the Las Vegas killings
within hours of the attack Giri Dan
Lee's name and his photo we're spread
across the Internet some Facebook users
saw the Las Vegas crisis response page
with a link to this gateway pundit
article in correctly identifying Giri
Dan Lee as the shooter calling him a
Democrat who associated with the anti
Trump army another link from the site
all right news speculated the attack was
the work of Isis they later apologized
for the mistake in a statement to CBS
News Facebook said it's Vegas false news
issue has been fixed quote we know
people want to see accurate information
on Facebook and so do we at Facebook
we're working to fight the spread of
false news people are looking for
answers during crisis and news events
Jonathan Albright has been tracking fake
news since the run-up to the 2016
election he says the nature of social
media amplifies stories that are
blatantly false the authors are the
promoters of these of this type of fake
content often are seeking to shock
people to outrage them so if even if
people stop to investigate or dispute or
even debunk or especially things like
fact-check you're just getting kind of
more engagement with that which in
turn tends to reinforce the content
elsewhere late last month Mark
Zuckerberg talked about Facebook's false
news problems I wish I could tell you
that we're gonna be able to stop all
interference but that just wouldn't be
realistic on Monday Facebook handed over
to Congress 3,000 advertisements
purchased as part of a Russian linked
influence operation Congress is
investigating whether those ads seen by
about 10 million people interfered with
the 2016 election congressman Adam
Schiff is the top Democrat on the House
Intelligence Committee the American
people really need to see these ads they
need to see just how cynical these ads
are they need to see how the Russians
sought to divide us to turn American
against American congressman Schiff says
Silicon Valley needs to prove its
technology protects the public from
misinformation these algorithms can be
manipulated these searches can be
manipulated so that we're seeing what
people want us to see rather than the
true facts and that's a very destructive
to our society Facebook Twitter and
Google are expected to testify on the
hill next month congressman Schiff tells
us he wants the dubious Facebook ads to
become public as soon as possible and
notes that social media companies have a
long way to go in patrolling false news
stories there's a big debate as to
whether there should be a digital
version of the FCC this debate of course
will linger thank you so much